any moment now we're gonna get the uh
first moves of this game
yeah and i i like it i mean erob looks
very calm he looks he's got good posture
he looks he looks a lot calmer a lot
more at peace than he did i think in the
previous
previous part of part of it and he plays
the french okay
okay so who did he rob take lessons with
off stream
maybe botez is that possible he
definitely did not he has not been
streaming that much so
okay who did he take lessons with
because the french
that leads me to alexandria if i have to
blame anybody for a bad light square
bishop
alexandra feels like the person um
i mean maybe it was hot maybe i mean it
could be hans because hans gave him a
lesson
before his first game against foosley
maybe but i mean
but it would be it would be kind of odd
for him to be remembering this because
that was already one like
oh uh uh no no oh no no
queen no but maybe maybe charlie doesn't
see it charlie just sat back in a share
like he was like confused
charlie might not know wait a second
this could be brilliant by uh by erod
well we can actually listen in to
charlie right now so let's do that and
hear his thoughts about this position
take knight he takes with queen
i don't think he sees it yet
he's very quiet that's worth yeah i mean
i think there's a good chance that he
thinks he just blundered a pawn
this could be quite funny rob
i think i have to take it oh my gosh
what are you talking about he has to
take so he has that
okay so someone in the chats he was
doing i can just do this
i almost forgot wrong move order well no
i can't
carry the money he's still just going to
make this go erock come on man
come on let's bring home the w i'm just
going to try and get a little wacky i
just
um i just gave up that bishop idiot okay
okay okay he's just gonna he can't take
okay
still very very very very messy
like i mean playing like both players
players are very likely to make mistakes
here because because they're sort of
unfamiliar and the other thing is the
way the position is
with where the pieces are it's there's
like the pawns
there aren't any pawns in the center of
the board so i think this is uh
i really think this is anyone's game
yeah i mean this mistake
this bishop v5 check it's an
understandable one he he saw the knight
and the queen on the same line and so he
wanted to move the piece out of the way
but if we just go back for that half
second knight takes d4 first
queen takes the fourth then bishop d5
checks the king
and wins this queen on d4 by four so
right
plan wrong execution and then erog
sometimes these backwards moves in this
case
knight back to capture are hard to find
and so he didn't do it and after c6
then charlie took on oh ah
what huh huh
i think he forgot that the queen was now
attacking the square
something so am i in danger not a
transposition
to knight takes d4 queen takes over
first but through very different
means
and we're listening to charlie again oh
yikes
[Music]
and charlie's too quiet for my liking
right now because usually he's got a lot
to say
now he's yeah i mean i you know what i
think is maybe with charlie he actually
realized he did the wrong order and then
he realized he got lucky that that e rob
did this order so he's now i think maybe
he's like he's like kind of hesitant
because he realizes that he did the
wrong order so
i think he might just be a little bit
rattled but again he is up one queen
here for one bishop so he should
uh my senses are overloaded i'm getting
a phone call
um i don't know what i'm i don't know
what
[Music]
but i still expect him to find some good
moves here i think this should be pretty
straightforward
yeah and he was saying that he senses or
overload he's getting a phone call
but he's up a queen so he said i should
just follow my instincts and he took
this pawn f6
now he's queen's attacking this rook and
i think he'll try to go for some sort of
checkmate with bishop to g5 and get the
queen
next to the king it's just a very quick
attack so it's a queen for one minor
piece
but not nearly enough compensation for
for iran yeah i mean i think as long as
as charlie castles the king i don't
really see
i don't i don't really see how he can uh
it's just it doesn't look like there's
enough compensation for erod here bishop
g5 is
is is already i think very close to
winning um
so it's it's a very tough spot to be in
for
for uh for e-rob for sure and for
charlie to
be able to win this game very quickly i
think that should help his confidence
because i have
watched his streams not necessarily
while he's playing in the pogchamps but
when he just playing chess on his own
and there are times where i feel like he
gets a little
rattled and he just questions his
judgment but he actually is quite a
strong player he's really improved
and well here's an interesting moment
erob attacks the queen if it goes to g5
hikaru
maybe we'll see iran with the discovery
with his rook and bishop on the g
file move the bishop out the way and
then win this queen on g5
right and that that would be uh well it
would actually be probably a better
transition i think for uh
for for for charlie because there would
be one less piece on the board but in in
general um yeah i think it's just a
matter of getting the king out of the
center of the board
and uh and charlie should be doing fine
now here erov should play bishop to d7
and gambit the pawn on b7 hoping that
charlie doesn't see it
because really the the only thing that
black has here is the two bishops
so you need to try and create some some
threats even if even if
uh it gives up material yeah it's a good
point
especially because you know every player
misses a tactic here and there and
bishop d7 maybe charlie will think okay
he's just developing
and forgets that the queen is eyeing
this pawn on b7 and as you said if that
bishop gets to c6
now we're starting to get chances for
black
right exactly yeah and
well you're up thinking he plays bishop
d7 good move
very good move i like i like it i like i
like the i
actually you know what i like as well
when i'm looking at e um he saw it
when i'm looking at ebrob like he he
doesn't look really unhappy he doesn't
look
like now he shakes his head a little bit
but he doesn't look super upset like
like previously when he was behind in
the games you could just sort of get the
sense that he felt it was just over and
he had no chances but he seems
he seems much more relaxed even though
he's behind if he can keep
keep keep calm i do think there still is
a chance that uh
charlie could make make a blunder um uh
down the road
yeah that's true and will queen takes b7
is step one in the right direction for
charlie he gets rid of this pawn
which also stops this bishop from coming
to c6 so that's the real problem is
it's down a queen e rob is and he can't
coordinate his pieces rook state's a
good move
getting the rook to the open file
by rob he wants to play bishop c6 but
icaru this rook on c8 needs that
bishop's defense so unfortunately
black is going for the right plans just
not enough material
and not enough protective pieces to be
able to make it work
right yeah so i i think in general i
mean again the main thing that charlie
needs to do here is just get his king
out of the center of the board
with these pawns in front of it his king
will never be able to come under attack
and once he does that i think i i think
it's going to be very hard for for iran
to create threats against the king and
then he can bring the rooks to open
files
so it seems seems like it should be
pretty straightforward barring
barring um now c3 is fine um
again i would have preferred if he
castled the king but
still the game the game goes on right
and there is
some faint hope of eventually playing
bishop c6 but not with this rook
undefended that's the real issue here
and if black were castled then bishop c6
figure
look at that move king e7 i like it yeah
yeah it's uh i mean again you still have
the threat of moving the bishop to c6
but uh nonetheless charlie is using a
fair amount of time he's
he's not moving super quickly so uh
again
we need to see what the next couple of
moves present if charlie finds probably
three to four good moves i think he's
almost certainly gonna win this
game but you never know players have
made made mistakes in other games and
bad things have happened so
um you never you never know and that's
why we're watching this for sure and
there's the empty frappuccino
on the king side without this bishop on
g2 so
maybe charlie would be worried the empty
frappuccino
you know box box calls it the
frappuccino instead of the keto
no okay dude whatever everybody's got a
different name for this i don't i don't
even know what it's like everyone has a
different name
i think i've heard hut i've heard hat
i've heard sniper's nest i've heard
the empty frappuccino like i've heard
everything now i've literally heard
everything
he calls the frappuccino but it's empty
so i figured i'd call it the
the finished frappuccino let's call it
that or not
we don't have to are you doing anything
on on the fianchetto or you're doing a
takeout on like an actual the actual
drink
so because fianchetto was obscured to
albert he started calling it frappuccino
instead okay
okay all right okay okay because i was
trying to i was trying to see the
formation it didn't look like a coffee
cup
but yeah it's it's all good it's all
good okay
all right i'm just hyped up on that much
sugar from my frappuccinos that now i
see it everywhere no it's just
right exactly yeah except
oh so queen takes an a7
charlie is just eating everything that's
put in this pad
and maybe erupts just keep going after
charlie's queen
feels like yeah i mean i think um i
think rook 8 would be the best try here
again it's a very tough position i mean
just you've already down a queen here so
it's gonna be very difficult but i think
he needs to keep
keep um he needs to keep uh keep
attacking the queen if you can
yeah and let's go back to charlie to
hear his thoughts to see how he's
handling this
what happens is that basically uh you
have a chance so like
normally and this is what i like because
if this is the best of one it'd be like
oh man like i lost the game this is it
like you know
it feels i feel so unsaturated you saved
one
two you get erob is going to get a shot
with the white
chuck here to start to
start the comeback and and uh and the
redemption arc
for sure and we have charlie on right
now he
you know he saw that capture right away
he realized that you know move his king
away from his bishop which i still can't
take
and
yeah i think um uh
yeah and by the way since i do this is
best of two it's not best of all
the players
is leading to a forced checkmate so uh i
think at this point
yeah it's it's just about over but
as i said there's going to be a second
game so erod will have a chance in the
second game with the white pieces to uh
to try and mount to come back he
certainly will and
i mean charlie i still have mo up here
he saw queen c7 he's thinking that this
also wins him with bishop
because the king then i take his bishop
last rank but as you're putting him in
check again which is going to force him
up
right exactly actually can i win
and honestly i'm tempted to accept the
draw he has been doing a lot of puzzles
i kind of want to but you see does he
rob realize it's best of two cause he
just offered a draw
pushing up right now one more time
then draw for his classic yeah sorry
checkmate okay so first game okay so
it's one nothing
yeah and well that was a suspicious
start
for charlie if we just go back in time a
little bit i mean
the opening was good for both players i
think they were following their
principles very well this knight was
brought to c3 to protect the pawn
fourth standard opening theory and we
saw the trade
and knight of six so somebody taught you
about you know this very i mean
it probably was hans i'm guessing on the
first day that's because that's the only
person that i know of that he took a
lesson with
um i mean maybe maybe he actually just
looked he just went and took a lesson
off stream or perhaps he looked at
something
um maybe it's like on wikipedia or
somewhere i i don't know
but um chad would probably know because
because that that was on stream the
first lesson was on stream so chat would
know if if this was an opening that hans
prepared
or if this was on something did they
look at this on stream or did he just
discover this off stream i'm i'm i'm
looking at channels well i'm asking chat
too because
because the thing is like the first
lessons that hans did with erob they
were on stream so
there were vods they were remembered but
i don't know if they were on stream or
this is something he found
found separately uh on his own which is
also entirely possible by the way
completely possible that he found this
on his own um yeah
and you know he went after knight f6
charlie reacted well by capturing
then g takes and then this is also a
good move yeah
yeah and you know kind of very natural
play by both sides developing their
pieces putting pressure and
protecting the center and then after
bishop d3 this was really the critical
moment
where knight takes d4 was yeah this one
mistake um yeah probably
but i mean the reason i'm actually
starting to think that maybe he this
wasn't something that anyone prepared
for him is because normally you would
not bring your night out you'd bring
your bishop out
um instead of putting the knight on c6
so i'm not so sure i mean
this might just been something that he
came up with on with on his own actually
because you put the bishop on d7 and
then c6 if you
like if you're showing this opening i
think you would go bishop d7 bishop c6
at least that's what a coach would
instruct you to play so i'm actually
thinking more and more that maybe that's
just something that he came up with
on his own yeah and it almost worked out
in his favor because after knight c6
bishop d3 knight takes d4 which
is a blunder because of knight takes
first the wrong move order of bishop b5
check
should have netted e-rob a piece on b5
okay although i see someone i see a
certain grand master in chat is saying
that he prepared charlie for this line
so maybe actually maybe
rob did play this in in uh in a previous
game perhaps and maybe maybe that that's
so maybe this was not his first time
playing this opening um and i was just
unaware of the game that he robbed
played because it seems like this is
something that was prepared
so uh so maybe maybe erov had already
looked at this opening before
and unfortunately for him he got the
position he must have wanted with the
bishop hanging he put his pawn c6 and
then sadly for him he took back
and lost his queen right and then then
it was just uh then there was nothing
nothing really that he could do there
well let's get this next game going
because i'm sure
iran wants his revenge and we'll see
what he's prepared with the white side
because clearly he's worked on his
openings as you said like
either by himself or with a you know one
of the coaches
but it feels like he may have something
up his sleeve and quickly
bust out e4 so so far so good i i mean
whoa oh whoa
is he going for the form of checkmate
you know a little something about queen
h5 early don't you
come on bishop c4 come on
oh oh good developing move
but you know you want to go for the
check mate immediately bishop c4 hits f7
the second time okay so yeah so i mean
charlie sees it right away okay um
and okay he he thought for a little bit
so i was wondering if he would retreat
the queen of where too he brings it back
to f3
but the problem with this square is now
this knight can come into d4 with
another
tempo and the queen and again right and
it's going to get very ugly very quickly
since the rob confused the move order
but
charlie plays bishop c5 which also i
like because it's just he's sticking to
the principles
um which which is very important like as
you're playing against better players in
the bracket it's going to be important
the principles are going to matter more
than actual tricks because people will
see the trick ideas so i like that he's
following principles and still
developing pieces here
yeah he's getting himself ready to
castle he's fended off any sort of
checkmate throughout an f7
and if your erog i guess now bishop c4
you know should be played but it does
feel a bit too slow because earlier
bishop c4 would have the tempo attacking
f7
now f7 is guarded because the queen is
blockaded on the f file so
carl what kind of moves would you
suggest for erod here i mean
to complete his development but what
kind of setup should he go for um
probably should bring the bishop out to
c4 and then try to develop the knight
and get the king out of the center
um it's a tough position though okay it
goes 95
yeah i mean this it's not a bad move per
se
the one thing i like about what's
happening is that uh
it is that basically white is trying to
attack towards the king side i guess the
problem is that white is sacrificing a
lot of development here
because black can trade the knights and
then start attacking the white
white queen going all over the board so
i
i don't mind this but the problem is
that if charlie remembers the
fundamentals of like just
following through with the development
there is a chance that this could get uh
be very ugly for erob in a hurry yeah
and i
agree with you i like that his
aggressive intentions he is down one
point and needs to win
to even up the score but he sacrificed
so much in terms of development that
it feels like charlie's play is quite
natural but
charlie's sitting and thinking right now
and he has to be worried about knight
takes f6
which will shatter his kingside pawn
structure
right so i i think knight takes night is
a pretty obvious move but
i feel like based on what i think most
most of the coaches have even shown
they're showing the players or what
they've seen
it's not kind of a normal it's just not
a normal
sort of idea that you see right away so
i think it's just a little bit
it's just a different kind of kind of
position which i i think is why
why charlie is not so sure as far as
what to do here
well why don't we sit back and just let
everybody hear
charlie's thoughts because he's in a
critical moment right now
is this in any immediate danger
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna let this
happen to be honest
so i think i'm just gonna castle now
well
i don't know this is confusing i don't
know i don't know what this is i have
literally never seen this before
the only thing pressured is this in my
night
but him taking my knight doesn't make
any sense because then i take with my
pawn it ruins my pawn structure
but he can't take it back or anything i
i'm just going to develop normally i'll
i don't know
whatever happens happens i guess
i will say erob is a a very tricky
opponent
he's using techniques i've never even
thought
should exist
[Laughter]
i took two minutes on that move wow
wow
i'm just going to stick with my my
normal plan
his self-awareness is really an all-time
high it is yeah it is yeah i'm surprised
that he noticed that he used two minutes
um i mean he rob is doing reasonably
well he's just
he's got to develop he's only as one i
imagine he'll bring bishop
out actually
interesting so yeah he thinks that now
iran will bring the bishop out but he
did notice that
well in europe took on f6 but he charlie
noticed this he saw this is going to
happen but he was so
shocked because in his standard lessons
people don't
you know use the same piece so many
times the knight moved twice right
right i think i mean this is one of the
issues of course when you try to prepare
players is that if
if the players play something they're
not used to and i mean this is what what
erod did is not a good opening idea
but if but if you if you aren't aware of
why it's not good and you haven't seen
it before it's very easy to get a little
bit flustered and confused as to what is
going on so
um i think that's one of the one of the
trickiest things when you're trying to
coach some of these players just
for them to follow a basic idea because
when you see something very weird like
this
it just doesn't really fit with the plan
but i think charlie is doing fine
he is probably slightly better i think
the main issue for erob is he has to get
the bishop in the night out he's really
got to develop his piece because he's
way behind in the development phase of
the game right now so
um he really needs to just bring his
bishop and bring his night out
yeah it must be frustrating for erod
because you want to pile up
i just accidentally pulled oh no no that
was me that was me
oh oh okay okay okay okay okay
i'm sorry i didn't mean to do it okay
okay place h3
okay um oh i was trying to draw an arrow
and i accidentally clicked on the square
and i was trying to say that you want to
pile pressure on this okay
[Laughter]
thank you for that robert thank you oh
my my pleasure that's what i'm here for
you know just to blunder my queen when
it
it's uh you guys right so okay so it
goes h3 which is
which is a completely reasonable move
here i want i'm kind of curious what
charlie is going to do in this position
because
i feel like normally what you want what
the plans revolve around is castling
your king out center of the board um but
he he does find knight d4 which is a
very good move
i was wondering if he would see this
move so he's attacking the queen
attacking the pawn i think e rob should
see the queen move
both queen moves makes sense i think
he'll probably go to d3 although he
could go to d1
so um it's important that he moves the
queen and protects this pawn on c2
right and there's nothing for this queen
to attack so i don't think he can be too
distracted because the move like queen
g3
while you're taking an open file and
maybe trying to bring your queen into a
menacing position
you're not actually attacking anything
directly so it doesn't feel worth it
if you're thinking in their shoes right
so i think yeah probably dropping the
queen back makes a lot of sense here um
but again
oh no that's you right no no that was
you
nope no that was you it wasn't me this
time
oh no yeah he had the right idea
of bringing the queen to protect the
pawn he
[Music]
do you want to offer a draw and we're
tuning in to charlie again to hear
his thoughts and well
the game's over that's fair that's
that's fair
oh man
that's unfortunate he just said he would
have accepted a draw if it was offered
which wouldn't change the match score at
all obviously because right but
you hate you hate to see it end like
that um because the e-rod
tri was moved the queen out of the
attack and he just had to move it over
to c3 or d3 um
unfortunately moved to b3 and uh yeah
very very difficult obviously very very
tough
tough match for for erod considering in
the first game probably for one move he
was winning the game so very uh
very very very tough for erod and i feel
like i
accidentally cursed him so i'm going to
take partial blame here
because of my misclick yeah i mean i
think it was just it was difficult i
mean he's going up against charlie who's
who's put in a lot more time um
obviously rob's been busy with other
things which which of course are far
more
important um but i think the fact that
charlie's put a lot of time he came with
some basic setups and erod kind of
he didn't have a basic opening set of it
felt like at any point in this
tournament
it really i think affected him in a kind
of in a negative way
i would say for sure and you know he did
have some good ideas like he was coming
up with a unique approach to this game
at this critical moment here he had the
right idea just
unfortunately he must have forgotten
that the knight also hits b3
so focused on f3 and c2 that's something
you just forget that this third square
is also under attack
right exactly yeah so i mean very very
very difficult
um difficult couple of games for erod
but again i mean i i thought that he
played
he played reasonably well for the first
like 10 moves or thereabouts in the
first game and he had a chance to be
taking this bishop with the knight
uh oh did he miss click oh no don't tell
me he misclicked
someone in chat to the action miss click
but i i i don't know if he did
um but he wasn't streaming so i don't
know how anybody would
ah this is true this is true yeah good
point um at any rate very difficult
uh very very tough for for era but
certainly i mean i think you keep
you keep your head high um and uh and
and just i think the takeaway is he did
get that one win against voyboy and he
did play he did play well in that game
against voyboy specifically who was one
of the tournament favorites and today
in that first game he had this one one
opportunity where if he
found this knight takes bishop move he
would have had great chances to win win
this first game maybe the whole match
would have been different then
so i i feel bad for um
i feel bad for erod but i hope that at
least he learned something and
he he he had uh he had he had a good
good experience
you know it was all about this center
night today it was
two times a night on d4 was what caused
him grief the first time it was his
night
and then um you know a second time was
his opponent's night but
maybe just when you're learning chess
you focus on certain parts of the board
and you
struggle to remember the knight because
it goes in some weird ways it goes to b5
and b3 and if you're already focusing
the other side of the board it can cause
some distractions
right exactly yeah so i think maybe that
maybe that's the uh
i mean it's just difficult but but
certainly i think if he gets a little
bit more awareness
um then perhaps in the future these
mistakes won't happen and even if he
doesn't really play much more chess as
long as as long as he tries to
tries to learn some of these basic
patterns and he he has a little bit of
fun with it i think that's that's that's
more than you can ask for so i i think
uh
hopefully hopefully at a good time and
and he enjoyed it
for sure and we're gonna go on a very
quick break so that when we come back we
will have an interview
uh with at the very least voice critical
and hopefully also erupt so stay tuned
everybody we will be
right back and we are back joined now by
both
morris critical and erup congratulations
charlie that was a
pretty great performance hey thank you
man i appreciate that
i can't take all the credit for it it is
again the prophet daniel nardinski he
pretty much predicted
most of the moves erod would make it
he's got like the third eye
he's crazy man he can see everything
before it happens so i prepped
i knew what to expect and where to go
it's kind of like a real-life cheat code
and e-rob what about you it seemed like
you had a pretty solid opening
especially in that i
clicked i misclicked i meant i was you
know how you right-click and you can
like show what move you want to do
or whatever i was trying to get rid of
that and so i just clicked
and it moved me to b3 where were you
trying to go
in that section i wanted to go to c3
because i thought he was going to
take my pawn and then uh split me
so get my uh castle or my king right
and i i must take part of the blame here
because i actually misclicked while we
were doing coverage just to move earlier
where i was trying to show you putting
pressure on this pawn f6 and i
accidentally
misclicked and took it so i uh i get
what
happened completely it's frustrating
so so erob i actually had a question the
first game you actually were winning
in the opening part of the game um i
know robert if you can show this
position
uh i was kind of curious if in this
opening you saw this move
what's that keep going if you realize
that after this bishop check you could
have played knight takes bishop
um i didn't see that
because if you played that you would
have just been ahead by one bishop oh my
yeah i had me sweating hard during
stream
ah are you serious oh man that was i was
greasing my ass real hard because you
took a little while to make your next
move i was like
i just and i just threw my queen away
yeah yeah
now the funny thing is of course charlie
you had a you were winning if you played
the other order i don't know if you
realized this
afterwards you could have played knight
takes queen takes night and then made
the check
that's what i wanted to do because that
was something that i was doing earlier
in practice and i think during the game
i just i went a little too fast i mean i
don't know what's going on with the cell
phones but i got called like
five times during it and then i don't
know man attention was all over the
place i
couldn't tell you what i was thinking
yeah and well erup did you work with any
coach because your opening was pretty
good in this game so i was wondering if
you kind of
i've been like just laying in bed
because i have a baby now
everyone knows and yep she just falls
asleep and i can't really get on my
computer and do anything else
and she'll start crying and i got to
take care of her so i've been playing
like 50 chess games a day
on my phone i just was sitting there all
day playing chess
so i just been learning i just been
practicing and learning new things
that's awesome and i mean it's been
working i understand of course this
matching go your way but
we were impressed by it seemed like you
were picking things up and your opening
itself was
a pretty good approach and charlie we
heard you you were surprised by what
year i was doing
yeah i actually uh a lot of the things
we practiced were like
here's some potential mistakes to look
for which he didn't really make the only
thing
that i didn't really get in the opening
was taking with the pawn over there
instead of the queen because it messed
up your pawn structure but everything
else seemed like right in line with like
the way to play the line
well to be clear taking with the pawn is
a pretty it is actually one of the
better moves but it's not
it's not something that that i think
most people would would necessarily pick
up on right away so it was an okay move
but i think certainly
it it would surprise you because
normally what you're being taught i
think is not to
stack the pawns one on the other but but
yeah so like erod
i'm kind of curious i i know it was very
difficult uh obviously first of all
congratulations
on on thank you i mean baby girl um but
did you did you sort of like did you
feel pressure today or were you just
kind of going in and trying to enjoy the
game
did you have funny rob yeah did you
enjoy yourself fun but i just messed up
twice it's so frustrating yeah
we've been i don't really feel pressure
but i don't know
i don't know yeah i mean it definitely
happens to all of us so i wouldn't be
too hard on yourself about it but you
you have made clear progress so i
i hope that you continue working on the
chest because
i think you're showing some good stuff
man thank you i like it it's a fun game
and uh charlie well you're still in the
bracket here
so what are your ambitions like uh i
just want to squeak out that fat 4k
consolation prize i dropped the match
against yasuo which i was real
disappointed in
because i prepped so long for and then
that was a bit of a blow to the ego i
started doing three minute matches
blowing fat ass during those
and then this just really needed to come
in and just go back to just the
fundamentals because
one tough loss like that sends you down
a crazy spiral i don't know if uh hikaru
or
robert if either of you have experienced
that but that downward spiral i was
contemplating buying crack under a
bridge at that point it was rough
it was sad wow well it seems like you
you ride the ship and you face the
winner of slicker
and swiftor so who would you rather play
and why
uh probably slicker just because i i
enjoy his streams so i think that'd be
fun i haven't seen too much from swiftor
but i've watched slicker before so i
think that'd be fun
yeah so i was going to add on that so
obviously charlie you're one of the
bigger trash talkers in the event
certainly i think it's it's well known
that
that slicker is is uh is has the same
kind of personality so uh
assuming you you play slicker i think he
is probably a clear favorite in that
match um do you have any any words
potentially that you'd like to
say in case you play him well just to
clear the air here because i recognize
sometimes in twitch chat picking up on
social cues is nearly impossible
when i'm talking it's just a joke i
obviously respect everyone i play
against and i like the majority of them
all of them really
so i'm not like actually coming for
these scalps or anything trying to like
ruin their careers on the chessboard
it's just for fun
but uh for slicker yeah i'm gonna spread
those cheeks wwe style i'm coming in hot
well you definitely uh you've made it
clear what your intentions are slicker
will probably
try to dance his way against you because
it seems like what he does every stream
but
i hope slicker's watching because i'm
sure he'll have words in return for you
if you end up
facing each other it sounds good to me
man this has been a lot of fun i really
appreciate the tournament guys and erob
great game and congrats again man
good game man well thank you both for
joining us
and we'll let you go and enjoy the rest
of your days and streams so thanks so
much again guys
yeah thank you take it easy everyone